THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN FASHION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ALLEN
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA. BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY COOPER. CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DALY. EGGMAN
FLORA.
PHONE
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON QUIRK QUIRK
SILVA REYES RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS
SANTIAGO STEINORTH.
STONE. THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER. WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE'LL START THIS AFTERNOON'S
MEETING.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THIS AFTERNOON'S PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE LED BY
THE ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN REVEREND
BOB OSHITA. REVENUES TO.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
IT WAS ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO
THAT I WAS SURPRISE.
TO REEXAMINE MY.
RESPECTIVE ON HIGH HALLWAY
UNCONSCIOUSLY VIEWED AIDS.
IT MUST HAVE BEEN AROUND
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT I WAS
MOVED BY A DOCUMENTARY ON
ALFREDO SOUTHSEA TAURUS.
ARTISTS SCULPTOR MURALIST
TEACHER AND MENTOR.
HE WAS A CONTEMPORARY OF THE
WELL KNOWN DIEGO RIVERA.
BUT IN HIS LIFETIME HE WAS
CONSIDERED THE MOST IMPORTANT
LIVING MEXICAN ARTIST.
NOT ONE SEEKING ACCOLADES ARE
REQUIRING PERSONAL VALIDATION.
IT IS SAID HE TURNED DOWN
MEXICO'S COVETED NATIONAL PRIZE
FOR ARTS AND SCIENCES A NUMBER
OF TIMES.
FINALLY ACCEPTING AT THE AGE OF
NINETY THREE.
THAT INTERVIEW WITH ALFREDO
SAUCE A TAURUS.
SO VIVIDLY REVEALED THAT HIS
CREATIVE VITALITY AND GENTLE
HUMOR REMAIN VIBRANT AT THE AGE
OF NINETY.
WHEN HE WAS ASKED.
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU WOULD WISH
FOR.
WITHOUT HESITATION HE SAID.
I WISH I COULD BE EIGHTY AGAIN.
I HAD SO MUCH MORE ENERGY WHEN I
WAS EIGHTY.
I RECALL HIM GENTLY LAUGHING.
BUT HE WAS ALSO MAKING A
MEANINGFUL POINT.
HOWEVER OLD WE MAY BE OR BECOME.
A PART OF US WILL ALWAYS WISH WE
COULD BE TEN YEARS YOUNGER.
HE CHANGED MY VIEW OF AGING.
FROM THAT MOMENT I BEGAN TO
EMBRACE THE DAYS OF MY LIFE. AS
A DREAM I WOULD WISH FOR TEN
YEARS FROM NOW.
IN OTHER WORDS THIS DAY AND AGE
WE ARE LIVING.
THIS MOMENT RIGHT NOW. IS A WISH
COME TRUE.
I WISH OUR FUTURE SELVES WILL
LONG FOR BUT CAN NEVER HAVE.
ALFREDO SOUTHIE TOURIST DIED AT
THE AGE OF NINETY FIVE IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE.
BUT I WILL ALWAYS REMAIN
GRATEFUL FOR HIS INSPIRATION TO
LIVE EACH DAY AS A DREAM COME
TRUE.
NOW MORE MEAN.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVENUE STEP. WE NOW
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING. AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE. JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES AS HE LEADS US
IN THE PLEDGE.
MEMBERS PLEASE PLACE YOUR RIGHT
HAND OVER YOUR HEART READY BEGAN
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THANK YOU CERVANTES YOU MAY BE
SEATED.
RE OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
MONDAY APRIL TWENTY THIRD TWENTY
EIGHTEEN
IT'S A MOMENTOUS ARE CALDERON
MOVES AND MISTER DOUBTED DALY
SECONDS.
THAT THE READING THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATION OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
WILL
.
KNOWING ABSENCES FOR TODAY FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BONTA CHEN AND
CUNNINGHAM ARE EXCUSE
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHT
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND QUIRK
SILVA TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER IS GUESTS WILL BE IN
THE AREA OF THE MEMBER'S DEATH
AND AT THE ROSTER FOR LATINO
SPIRIT AWARDS CEREMONY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS.
BAKER GRAYSON AND A PACK WE ARE
CURRY TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN AND
MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO COMMITTEE. AS THE ONE SEVENTY
FOUR LADA FROM THE UTILITIES
ENERGY COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND S. B. THREE NINETY
TWO BATES FROM THE BUSINESS IS
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
SOMETHING MEMBER HARPER PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM NINETY NINE AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY NINE GRAY FROM
THE CONSENT CAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON THE
CLERK WILL KNOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
MOVE TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX TO WITHDRAW THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE IN ORDER THEM TO THE
SECOND READING FILE. SB EIGHT
FORTY AND AB EIGHTEEN OH SEVEN
THROUGH AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY SIX INCLUSIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON MISS
WALDRON WHY DO YOU HAVE. FOR A
PURPOSE YOU RISE HOW WE OBJECT
TO THE MOTION AND ASK FOR ROLL
CALL.
VERY GOOD MISS WALDRON.
I MISS WALDRON HAS REGISTERED
OBJECTION MISTER CALDERON HAS
MOVED.
TO WITHDRAW TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX TO WITHDRAW THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FROM BUDGET
COMMITTEE IN ORDER THEM TO THE
SECOND READING FILE. SB EIGHT
FORTY AND HE BEAT EIGHTEEN OH
SEVEN THROUGH AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
SIX INCLUSIVE.
MISTER CALDERON HAS MOVED MISTER
GIBSON HAS SECOND.
GLOBAL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AN I. MISS WALDRON IS ASKING
FOR A NO.
IT TAKES TWENTY ONE VOTES.
LITTLE HOLES IN ROLL EYES OR
FORTY THREE KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT
MOTION PASSES.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
GUESTS WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY.
WILL.
START WITH THAT MS BAKER A
SUMMER BAKER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY MS BAKER
AND WILL GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN FOR HIS GUEST
INTERACTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I MISTER SPEAKER IT'S MY
PRIVILEGE TO WELCOME.
TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY UP MY
CONSTITUENTS VINCENT VICKY MARIO
AND THEIR DAUGHTER AARON.
I THEIR NEIGHBORS OF MINE BUT WE
HAD TO COME TO SACRAMENTO TO
HAVE TIME TO SPEND TOGETHER SO
WELCOME TED SACRAMENTO.
THANK YOU MAIENSCHEIN
A SIMILAR QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS IT'S MY PRIVILEGE AND
HONOR TO RECOGNIZE ON THE FLOORS
OF SOMEBODY WHO HAS DONE
SOMETHING THAT I DON'T BELIEVE
ANYBODY ELSE ON THIS FLOOR HAS
DONE. WHICH IS I WANT TO
INTRODUCE MY MOTHER.
JOSEPHINE AND SHE IS THE MOTHER
OF TEN CHILDREN.
JOYCE STAND UP AND I DON'T
BELIEVE ANYBODY ELSE ON THIS
FLOOR HAS DONE THAT. AND ALSO
WANT TO INTRODUCE MY TWO SISTERS
LYNETTE IN SUSIE AND ROTH BACK
HERE
MEMBERS WERE GONNA.
PROCEED AT THE LATINO.
THINK THIS.
SPIRIT AWARD CINCO DE MAYO.
CELEBRATION AND ASK YOU TO TAKE
YOUR SEATS
SOARING BRIT START WITH THE.
WITH THE AWARDS.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
SO WE CAN GET THE CEREMONY.
I STARTED
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
SO WE CAN BEGIN LATINO SPIRIT
AWARDS.
WE THE AYE FILE ITEM FORTY NINE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. HR ONE OH FOR
A FOR THE PURPOSES OF THIRD
READING.
HISTORY ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PROCEED WITH THIS ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
IT'S RESOLUTION ONE OF FOUR BY
FOUR
CARILLO RELATIVE TO CINCO DE
MAYO WEEK.
MISS KOREA.
THANK YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
TO COMMEMORATE THINK ALL THE MY
YOU. AND SUPPORT HOUSE
RESOLUTION ONE ALL FOR DECLARING
THINK ALL THE MY A WEEK.
THE ANNUAL TRADITION GIVES OF
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT ON
THE COURAGE BY THE MEXICAN ARMY
AT THE BUT THE IDEA THEY PUEBLA
OR THE BATTLE OF PUEBLA. AND
ALSO TO PLACE THEIR ACHIEVEMENTS
AND HISTORICAL CONTEXT IN ORDER
TO RECOGNIZE THEIR SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT.
THE HISTORY IT'S CHRONICLED IN
THE BOOK AND THINK OF THE MAYO
AN AMERICAN TRADITION.
BY PROFESSOR DAVID HAYES ABOUT
THESE THAT.
THE LATINO CAUCUS HAS DELIVERED
THE BOOK TO EACH OF YOUR OFFICES
AND I REALLY DO HOPE THAT YOU
GET AN OPPORTUNITY TO READ IT.
IN THIS ILLUMINATING HISTORY
PROFESSOR ABOUT THIS THAT
DESCRIBES THE LINK BETWEEN THE
BATTLE OF PUEBLA. AND THE DEFEAT
OF THE CONFEDERACY DURING THE
CIVIL WAR.
IN EIGHTEEN TEN.
FATHER MAKE ANY I'LL GO. HAD
PROCLAIM THE ABOLITION OF
SLAVERY IN MEXICO AND PRESIDENT
PERCENT THEY GOT A LITTLE. ONE
OF MEXICO'S REVOLUTIONARY
LEADERS WHO WAS AFRO MISSED THE
SOUL AND THE DESCENDANTS OF
SLAVES IN MEXICO SIGNED A DECREE
ABOLISHING SLAVERY IN EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINE.
IT TOOK NEARLY THIRTY SIX YEARS
AFTER MEXICO ABOLISHED SLAVERY
FOR THE U. S. TO RATIFY. THE
THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT IN EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FIVE IN ORDER TO END
SLAVERY IN THE UNITED STATES.
WHEN THE UNITED STATES SIGNED
THE TREATY OF WHETHER LUPE
THAT'LL GO AND EIGHTEEN FORTY
EIGHT WHICH ENDED THE MEXICAN
AMERICAN WAR.
THEY ACQUIRED THE SOUTHWEST
OUR BEAUTIFUL STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND PARTS OF WYOMING
AND COLORADO ALL LANDS AND
PEOPLE OF THAT LAND THERE WERE
ALREADY FREE. AND INDEPENDENT.
THIS IS WHY THE BATTLE OF PUEBLA
ON THE FIFTH OF MAY IN EIGHTEEN
SIXTY TWO.
CRITICAL.
THE OUTCOMES
WHAT EFFECT THE HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY IMMEDIATELY SOUTH OF THE
CONFEDERACY. AND THE U. S.
ALREADY ENGAGED IN THE CIVIL WAR
THAT LASTED FROM EIGHTEEN SIXTY
ONE TO EIGHTEEN SIX
FIVE. THIS IS THE CHRONICLE.
OF WHAT THIS TRULY MEANS.
AS THE FRENCH MARCHED INTO
PUEBLA THEY PLAN TO TAKE OVER
MEXICO AND USE THE COUNTRY. AS A
POTENTIAL BASE TO ASSIST THE
CONFEDERATE EFFORTS
AGAINST THE UNION.
IF BOTH THE FRENCH AND THE
CONFEDERACY
HAD BEEN SUCCESSFUL WITH THEIR
PLANS.
THERE WAS THE RISK THAT BOTH THE
SOUTH AND CENTRAL AMERICA WOULD
HAVE BEEN CHARACTERIZED BY
SLAVERY.
AN OLIGARCHY.
FORTUNATELY.
THE INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF PUEBLA
AS WELL AS THE MEXICAN SOLDIERS
DEFEATED THE FRENCH ON MAY FIFTH
EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO.
WELL TO BE WELL IT'S GONNA BE A
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A FEW MORE
YEARS BEFORE. THEY TRULY ARE
DEFEATED THE FRENCH
THERE BRAVERY IS STILL
REMEMBERED AND HONORED ANNUALLY.
LET US REMEMBER SINGLE THAN I A
FOR WHAT IT TRULY IS.
A DAY OF JUSTICE EQUITY
INDEPENDENCE
FREEDOM.
THE SINGLE THE MY HOLIDAY HAS
SINCE EXPANDED TO RECOGNIZE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF LATINOS ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY.
FROM THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT
TO THE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
MOVEMENTS OF TODAY. I HOPE WE
ALL TAKE A MOMENT TO REFLECT.
ON THE INNER WOVEN INTERSECTION
OUT A HISTORY OF OUR PEOPLE AND
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF LATINOS
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
THANK YOU AND I URGE YOU AN AYE
VOTE ON.
OF THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS KOREA MISTER
JONES SAWYER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE THIS AFTERNOON ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF. HR
ONE OF FOUR. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FOR. WHICH CELEBRATES
AND RECOGNIZES THE STRENGTH OF
THE MEXICAN PEOPLE.
A STRENGTH THAT ENDURES TO THIS
DAY THAT YOU CONTINUE TO COMBAT
FROM AN ADMINISTRATION HAS TRIED
TO NEGATE YOUR ACCOMPLISHMENTS
BY CALLING YOU DEROGATORY NAMES.
A DISTORTION THAT WE AS AFRICAN
AMERICANS NOTE FAR TOO WELL.
AS WE TRIED RECLAIMING HISTORY
THAT EQUATED US TO CHATTEL FIVE
HUNDRED YEARS AGO BUT STILL HAVE
TO DEMAND TODAY. THAT ARE BLACK
LIVES MATTER.
SO I STAND HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS JOIN MY COLLEAGUES. OF
THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS TO CELEBRATE
VICTORY OVER TYRANNY.
LET US RECOGNIZE OUR SHARED
STRUGGLE MAKES US MORE ALIKE
THAN DIFFERENT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN AFRO MEXICANS
HELP PROMINENT HISTORY PROMINENT
PLACES IN YOUR HISTORY LIKE GAS
BAR. GAGNE.
OF FUGITIVE SLAVE CALLED THE
LIBERATOR OF THE AMERICAS APPEAL
PICO THE LAST MEXICAN GOVERNOR
OF OUT TO CALIFORNIA.
I PROBABLY SUPPORT HR ONE OF
FOUR AND ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THERE ANY FURTHER DEBATE
QUESTION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE.
SEEN HEARING NONE MISS CREEL YOU
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I LIKE
THE FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR
COLOR.
ALREADY HAVING CEASED WILL NOW
MOVE TO A VOTE ON THIS MEASURE
THE FIRST ROLL CALL WILL BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS ON A CHART ONE OF
FOR. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
MEMBERS THIS IS PRO CO AUTHORS
ON HR ONE OF FOUR.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
ARE SIXTY FIVE CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISS KOREA.
WE CAN NOW TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THIS ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
PLEASE SAY AYE. AYE. OTHERS POST
A NAY.
THE I IS HABIT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WILL MOVE TO OUR OUR
AWARDS CEREMONY SEVENTEEN YEARS
AGO THE CALIFORNIA LET
LEGISLATIVE LATINO CAUCUS
CREATED THE LATINO SPIRIT
AWARDS.
TO RECOGNIZE INDIVIDUALS WHO
EXEMPLIFY.
A TO SPIRIT OF OUR LATINO
CULTURE AND HERITAGE.
TODAY WE HONOR NINE INDIVIDUALS
WHO REPRESENT THE WIDE RANGE OF
TALENTS DOWN IN OUR INCREDIBLE
STATE.
I DON'T FOURTEEN AN ESCORT
COMMITTEE A TO BRING OUR SPECIAL
GUESTS ON TO THE FLOOR FOR
SPECIAL PRESENTATION.
NUMBER SHOULD RETIRE TO THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AS I CALL YOUR
NAME.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
CABALLERO.
CALDERON.
THE AUDIO.
EGGMAN.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
LIMON.
MEDINA.
QUIRK SILVA.
FRANCE.
RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO.
SALAS
SANTIAGO.
THURMAN.
AND NUMBER WEEKS MEMBERS WE HAVE
SOME SPECIAL GUESTS THIS
AFTERNOON AS WELL SENATORS DE
LEóN HERNANDEZ AND LARA.
WE'RE JOINED ESCORT COMMITTEE.
I ASK SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON IN
SPECIAL GUEST ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ASSEMBLY REPUBLICAN LEADER
PRIME.
LATINO CAUCUS CHAIR SENATOR BEN
HUESO AND VICE CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
TO MOVE TO THE CENTER AISLE TO
RECEIVE OUR HONOREES
.
MEMBERS WILL NOW MOVES TO THE
INTRODUCTION OF OUR LATINO
SPIRIT AWARD HONOREES FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
WE HONOR WE FOR FRIEND OF THE
LATINO COMMUNITY IS CHAUNCEY
BEACH
HE'S ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBERS
EDUARDO GARCIA AND THURMOND.
CHUNKY BEACH IS ARMY VETERAN
SCHOOL TEACHER AND LATINO
COMMUNITY CHAMPION
INSPIRED BY SAYS THERE CHAVEZ IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. WHERE DOES
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS BONTA
REGISTERING VOTERS?
AFTER DUTY IN THE U. S. ARMY
BEACH SOCKS CONTINUE HIS SERVICE
BY ENTERING THE TEACHING
PROFESSION.
HE TOOK A COACHELLA VALLEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT BECAUSE
OF THE LARGE MIGRANT FARM WORKER
COMMUNITY.
AS HE YOU ES DE HE ASK FOR
CLASSES PUBLIC NON ENGLISH
SPEAKERS STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS PREGNANT TEENS AND
STUDENTS INVOLVED WITH GANGS ARE
DRUGS.
BEACH TOOK THE TOUGH KIDS THE
DISILLUSIONED AND FILL THEM WITH
HOPE. HIS IMPACT ON THE STUDENTS
WAS RECOGNIZING TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO AS FEATURES NAME NATIONAL
TEACHER OF THE YEAR AND WAS
HONORED AT THE WHITE HOUSE
CEREMONY. PLEASE WELCOME THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FRIEND OF THE
LATINO COMMUNITY HONOREE TALK
THE BEACH.
THE HONOR REQUIRE ACHIEVEMENT
AND COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT IS
MELINDA CLAY ARE SHE IS ESCORTED
BY SOMETHING MEMBERS REYES AND
EIGHT MEN.
MELINDA AND PLAY OUR IS A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVOR AND A
CERTIFIED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ADVOCATE.
SHE WAS INVOLVED IN A SEVEN YEAR
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP THAT
ULTIMATELY CONCLUDED IN HER
JUMPING OUT OF HER CAR.
IF WE FROM HER FORMER SPOUSE WHO
KIDNAPPED HER AND HELD HER
HOSTAGE FOR SEVERAL HOURS AT
GUNPOINT.
WELL BOUNCING A FULL TIME JOB
TWO SONS THREE GRANDCHILDREN AND
OF THAT BAND.
LINDA FOUND THE TIME TO BECOME A
CERTIFIED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ADVOCATE.
WITH THEIR CERTIFICATION AND THE
SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE SHE GAINED
OF THE TRAINING COURSE MELINDA
LAUNCHED HER OWN NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION
DIVINE CONNECTIONS.
HOPE HOLD ON PAIN AND.
SHE HAS BECOME EXTREMELY ACTIVE
IN THE COMMUNITY AND HER SUPPORT
GROUPS FOR VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. HAS BECOME
A PASSION FOR MELINDA TO SHARE
HER VICTORIA'S STORY AND SHE'S
MOTIVATED TO SUPPORT AND EMPOWER
THOSE WHO CONTINUE TO BE BOUND
BY ABUSE.
PLEASE WELCOME THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ACHIEVEMENT AND
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT ON ARE YOU
GOING TO PLAY OUR.
WE HONOR WE FOR CHEAP
BUSINESS IN PHILANTHROPY AS FTP
AND SIGNS REPRESENTING THEM ARE
LIZETTE GIVING A LOPEZ.
JOSE ACRE BEING INVOLVED AND
MICHAEL JACOBINA
THEY ARE SUPPORTED BY FAMILY
MEMBERS SANTIAGO AND QUIRK
SILVA.
F. OPINION SIGNS IS CALIFORNIA'S
OWN COFFEE ROASTER LISTEN
RESTING SOME OF THE WORLD'S BEST
COFFEE INCLUDING FLAGSHIP
GOURMET BRAND DOT FRANCISCO'S
COFFEE MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS.
THE FAMILIES UNMATCHED COFFEE
EXPERIENCE AS COPY GROWS
INVESTORS FEEDBACK ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY YEARS TO THE RICH
COFFEE BEARING SOIL OF CUBA.
WHERE PAYCHECK DON FRANCISCO
GARDENIA HONED HIS SKILLS AS A
COPY PRODUCER?
THE FAMILY CARRIED ON THE COFFEE
TRADITION AND IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN ESTABLISHED ESCAPING AND
SONS INCORPORATED IN VERNE
CALIFORNIA.
TODAY THE COMPANY IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST FAMILY OWNED COFFEE
COMPANIES IN AMERICA. AND THE
NATION'S LARGEST PRIVATELY HELD
MINORITY ROASTER.
THEIR STATE OF THE ART PLANTS
STANDS AT OVER TWO HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET AND IS ONE
OF THE TOP COPY RESTING
FACILITIES IN THE COUNTRY. THEIR
BRANDS HAVE STRONG PRESENCE IN
WHOLESALE AND RETAIL ACCOUNTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND THIS
YEAR THEY OPEN DOT FRANCISCO'S
COFFEE BECAUSE THE CABANA THEIR
FIRST INTELLECTUAL CAFE IN
DOWNTOWN LA. IN ADDITION A
CONVENIENCE SONS IS VERY
COMMITTED TO THE COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY WORK AND LIVE.
THROUGH THE GIVING IT DIRECT
IMPACT INITIATIVE. THE SUPPORT
SEVERAL INTERNATIONAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND CONTRIBUTES
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED TERRIBLE
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE WELCOME THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ACHIEVEMENT IN THIS
EXAMPLE AFTER WE HONOR WE AT THE
MEDIA AND SENS COOPERATED.
THE ON-AGAIN JOURNALISM AND
MEDIA IS
THE LAMELLAE.
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBERS
ARAMBULA AND AGUIAR-CURRY.
WE'LL BE THE LAMELLAE HAS WORKED
AS A HOST OF THE RIVER VALLEYS
AND FOR ALL. IT WOULD EVEN SEND
TWENTY ONE FRESNO FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE YEARS IT IS THROUGH
THE SHOW THAT MOST LATINOS IN
THE VALLEY GET THEIR LOCAL STATE
AND NATIONAL NEWS.
AT WE NEED IS ON AND WE MUST
REPEAT THAT ALSO SERVES AS
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT.
OUTSIDE OF OFFICE THE PIZZA IS
AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE
COMMUNITY PARTICIPATES IN MANY
NONPROFITS AND ENSURES LATINO
VOICES HEARD.
SHE THE FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
LATINO ROTARY CLUB. BOARD MEMBER
OF CENTRAL LEFT MELIA AND IS A
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
THE PEOPLE ALSO CREATED PROJECT
HOPE. RICK THOUGH AS PRINT
ESPERANZA THAT RAISES FUNDS TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY. AND EVERY
YEAR HELPS ORGANIZE AND
PUBLICIZE EDUCATIONAL OUTREACH
EVENTS SUCH AS PASSED THE
WORKSHOPS THE VARIOUS SALUTE.
THAT VARIEGATED HE'S ON. AND
FRESNO STATE PLEASE WELCOME THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SHE'D MADE
JOURNALISM AND MEDIA HONOREE.
THE LAMELLAE.
THE HONOR REPORTS EVEN IN
MILITARY SERVICE AND ADVOCACY IS
HECTOR BROUGHT US FOR ELLA. HE
IS ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBERS
CARILLO AND RODRIGUEZ HECTOR
BRAS THRILLER IS ARMY VETERAN
WHO WAS RECENTLY GRANTED US
CITIZENSHIP. FOURTEEN YEARS
AFTER HE WAS DEPORTED TO MEXICO.
HE WAS BORN IN MEXICO EMIGRATED
WITH HIS FAMILY TO THE U. S. AS
A CHILD AND BECAME A LEGAL
PERMANENT RESIDENT IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO.
IN NINETEEN FIVE FOR A HAS A
BRAILLE LITE LISTED IN THE US
ARMY AFTER GRADUATING FROM HIGH
SCHOOL AND SERVED WITH
DISTINCTION UNTIL IT'S HONORABLE
DISCHARGE IN TWO THOUSAND ONE.
SOON THERE AFTER BRASWELL A LOST
HIS LEGAL RESIDENCY DUE TO A
CRIMINAL CONVICTION. AS DEPORTED
TO MEXICO. IN TWENTY THIRTEEN HE
OPENED A SHELTER AND TIJUANA FOR
OTHER DEPORTED VETERANS LIKE
HIMSELF.
THE DEPORTED VETERAN SUPPORT
HOUSE ALSO KNOWN AS THE BUNKER
PROVIDE SERVICES IN LEGAL
RESOURCES TO DEPORTEES ADJUSTING
TO LIFE OUTSIDE THE UNITED
STATES.
THE SUPPORT HOUSE HAS IDENTIFIED
AND MADE CONTACT WITH MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED FORTY MEN AND
WOMEN. FOR MORE THAN THREE DOZEN
COUNTRIES ON APRIL FIFTEENTH
TWENTY SEVENTEEN GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN PARDON FOR A HOUSE FOR THE
CLIENT CRIME. THE LETTUCE
DEPORTATION.
AND LET OF THIS PRODUCT HEARD
AND AND HIS EXEMPLARY MILITARY
SERVICE BROUGHT US FOR LESS TO
DECEIVE SHIP APPLICATION WAS
APPROVED AND HE IS NATURAL LIGHT
ON APRIL THIRTEENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
PLEASE WELCOME THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ACHIEVEMENT NOT TRADE
SERVICE AFFECTS THE HONOREE
HECTOR BROUGHT US FOR OUR.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN DYNAMIC YOU
THE WORD RECIPIENT
S. MISSPEAK AS TELEFLORA'S.
SHE'S ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBERS
SALAS AND CABALLERO.
BEATRIZ TELEFLORA'S COMES FROM A
LINEAGE OF FARM WORKERS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SHE MEANS
DEDICATED HER MISSION OF
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS AND SAFETY
OF IMMIGRANT WORKERS AND SERVICE
INDUSTRIES. THROUGH INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS THAT MERGE TECHNOLOGY
WITH SOCIAL JUSTICE.
THE SERBS AT THE FOUNDER OF THE
LATINO LEGACY FOUNDATION AND
THROUGH IT SHE HAS CREATED
COLOR.
THIS SMARTPHONE APPLICATION AIMS
TO DECREASE THE INCIDENCE OF
HEAT STROKE AMONGST FARMWORKERS
BY FETCHING LOCAL WEATHER DATA
TRIGGERING NOTIFICATION
FUNCTIONS. AND HOSTING
EDUCATIONAL CONTENT.
HER WORK FOR THE TEANECK
COMMUNITY HAS INSPIRED FEATURES
FROM NATIONAL NETWORKS. SUCH AS
WE DID ON NPR LATINO AND SUPPORT
FROM CELEBRITIES LIKE LYNN MAN
NUMBER AND THAT AND EVA
LONGORIA.
BATES PASSION FOR COMMUNITY
SERVICE AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
LETTER TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
HURLY FOUNDATION AS A FELLOW AN
AMBASSADOR.
AND TEN LEADERSHIP CONFERENCES
IN NEW YORK CITY AND WASHINGTON
DC.
PLEASE WELCOME THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DYNAMICALLY THE WORD
RECIPIENT MISSPEAK ESTELLA FLOOR
HAS.
THE ENRIQUE WHICH EVEN IN.
SHE IS ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER
RUBIO AND SENATORS HERNANDEZ AND
LARA.
LIZ HERNANDEZ AS A MEXICAN
AMERICAN TELEVISION PERSONALITY
NBC'S ACCESS HOLLYWOOD AS ONE OF
THE ENTERTAINMENT NEWS PROGRAMS
FIRST LATINA CORRESPONDENCE.
BORN AND RAISED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HERNANDEZ SERVED AS
THE LONGTIME CO HOST OF THE
NUMBER ONE RATED AND NATIONALLY
SYNDICATED MORNING SHOW. BIG
BOY'S NEIGHBORHOOD ON LOS
ANGELES IS INFLUENTIAL POWER ONE
OF SIX F. AND.
SHE FIRST MADE THE JUMP FROM
RADIO TO TELEVISION IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN WHEN SHE BEGAN
WORKING AS A CORRESPONDENT FOR
MTV NEWS.
SHE ALSO SERVED AS ON AIR TALENT
FOR ANTI TRACE FOR JOINING ENEWS
AND TWENTY ELEVEN AS A
CORRESPONDENT AND HOST IT THE
NEWS NOW.
HERNANDEZ IS ALSO A STRONG
SUPPORTER AND ADVOCATE FOR THOSE
CARING FOR AND LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
SHE HAS MODERATED PANELS ON
WOMEN ALZHEIMER'S AND MET
LEGISLATIVE AND CONGRESSIONAL
LEADERS ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
THE CAUSE. AND SHE USES HER
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM TO RAISE
COMMUNITY AWARENESS
PLEASE WELCOME THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ACHIEVEMENT IN MEDIAN
ENTERTAIN HONOR ME LIZ
HERNANDEZ.
THE HONOREE FOR TEAM AND PARTS
AND INTO
PAYMENT IS
MARIN.
HE'S ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBERS
MEDINA AND LIMON.
CHEECH MARIN AS AN ACTOR
DIRECTOR WRITER MUSICIAN ART
COLLECTOR IN HUMANITARIAN.
HE IS BEST KNOWN AS HALF OF THE
SATIRICAL DUO CHEECH AND CHONG.
TOGETHER RELEASED VARIOUS ALBUMS
SIX WHIPPLE FORMER NOMINEE FOR
GRAMMYS AND ONE LET'S GO SHE
KNOWS.
WHEN THE NINETEEN SEVENTY THEE
GRAMMY FOR BEST COMEDY
RECORDING.
HE IS ALSO RECOGNIZED TODAY AS A
PREEMINENT CHICANO ARE ADVOCATE.
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES HE
STARTED COLLECTING CHICANA ARE.
HIS INAUGURAL EXHIBITION CHICANO
VISIONS AMERICAN PAINTERS ON THE
VERGE. BROKE THE ATTENDANCE
RECORDS DURING ITS
GROUNDBREAKING FIFTEEN CITY
TOWARDS MAJOR ART MUSEUMS ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES.
TO FURTHER POLITICAL TO
INTRODUCE CHICANO ART TO A WIDER
AUDIENCE
CHIEF PARTNERED WITH THE CITY OF
RIVERSIDE AND RIVERSIDE ART
MUSEUMS CREATE THE MARIN CENTER
FOR CHICANO ART CULTURE AND
HISTORY.
SLATED TO OPEN TWENTY TWENTY THE
CHEECH WILL BECOME THE PERMANENT
HOME FOR HIS MORE THAN SEVEN
HUNDRED WORKS OF
KANDAHAR. INCLUDING PAINTINGS
SCULPTURES AND PHOTOGRAPHY
COLLECTIVELY THE MOST RENOWNED
CHICANO ART COLLECTION IN THE
UNITED STATES.
PLEASE WELCOME TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ACHIEVEMENT IN ARTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT HONOREE CHEECH
MARIN
.
HE HONOR REQUIRED TREATMENT IN
BUSINESS AND ENTERTAINMENT IS
CAP ON THE SHEETS ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AND
SENATOR DE LEON.
KAPLAN THE STORY BEGINS THE
SMALL THRILL OF CITY OF MONTHLY
MORELOS MEXICO WHERE SHE WAS
BORN.
A HERITAGE SHE CELEBRATES AND
HER ARTWORK
SHE'S A TALENTED TATTOO ARTIST
OFF THEIR MUSICIAN ACTIVIST AND
A SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS WOMAN.
CAPPING AND TATTOOING AT THE AGE
OF FOURTEEN AND LOS ANGELES AND
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN OPEN HIGH
VOLTAGE TAX YOU IN WEST
HOLLYWOOD.
SHE STARTED HER OWN TELEVISION
SHOW LA INK
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT CAPTIVE
THE WORLD BY STORM WITH HER
EXTREME PERFORMANCE MAKE UP
COLLECTION CAP ON THE BEAUTY.
JUST SOLD EXCLUSIVELY
INTERNATIONALLY AT SUPPORT. SHE
HAS ALSO RELEASED THREE BUCKS
HIGH VOLTAGE TAX YOU THE TAXI
CHRONICLES AND GO BIG OR GO HOME
WHICH ONLY THE NEW YORK TIMES
BESTSELLERS LIST.
CATS PASSION FOR ANIMALS
HUMANITY AND THE ENVIRONMENT HAS
INSPIRED HER ACTIVISM
SHE IS EFFECTIVELY UTILIZED HER
BUSINESS TO RAISE FUNDS FOR A
VARIETY OF ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING. PROJECTS CHAMPS AND
ALL SANCTUARY THE FARM SANCTUARY
AND CALIFORNIA WILDLIFE CENTER
LEADER THIS YEAR CAT WILL BE
RELEASING HER DEBUT ALBUM AND
HER VEGAN SHOE LINE BOND ISSUES.
PLEASE WELCOME THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ACHIEVEMENT IN BUSINESS
AND ENTERTAIN HONOREE CAP ON
THE.
MEMBERS OF ANOTHER ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR ALL OF OUR LOCAL
AUTHORITIES DESCRIBE.
I THOUGHT I ALSO LIKE TO KNOW AS
THE MANY OTHER HONORED GUESTS
WHO ARE HERE TODAY TO CELEBRATE.
A WITH THE LEGISLATURE WELCOME
EVERYONE WHO SIT IN THE GALLERY
TO SUPPORT OUR HONOREES
JOIN US FOR THIS IMPORTANT
OBSERVANCE.
WE'LL MOVE NOW TO OUR KEYNOTE
ADDRESS
I TODAY'S KEYNOTE SPEAKER IS AN
AMERICAN CARTOONIST AND AUTHOR
OF LA CUCARACHA THE FIRST
NATIONALLY SYNDICATED
POLITICALLY THEMED. LATINO DAILY
COMIC STRIP.
MEMBERS PLEASE WELCOME MISTER
LAWLER. OUR COMMENTS.
RIGHT LITTLE BOX.
I EVERYBODY.
MY NAME IS LAWLER HOME
CARTOONISTS.
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HEART OF THE
RESISTANCE.
IT IS AN HONOR FOR ME TO BE HERE
WITH YOU AS YOU PRESENT. THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN LATINO SPIRIT
AWARDS.
BUT YOU KNOW SPIRIT AWARDS WERE
CREATED MORE THAN SEVENTEEN
YEARS AGO TO HONOR THE AMAZING
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT LATINOS ARE
MAKE.
AND ALL WALKS OF LIFE ACROSS THE
MOST BEAUTIFUL POWERFUL AND SEXY
IS STATE IN THE UNION
CALIFORNIA.
THE BLOODY.
GREAT CROWD.
BY THE WAY CALIFORNIA JUST
SURPASSED THE UK TO BECOME THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD.
THAT MAKES CALIFORNIA THE MOST
POWERFUL COUNTRY ON THE PLANET
WITH REALLY GOOD DOCTORS.
SORRY MEXICO.
I WAS HONORED WITH THIS AWARD
THE SECOND YEAR.
YOU GAVE THEM OUT IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR SO I GUESS THEY
WERE HANDING THEM OUT IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER.
THE RECIPIENTS OF THE LATINO
SPURTS OF SPIRIT AWARDS HAVE
BEEN ROLE MODELS IN THEIR FIELDS
AND THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS
CALIBRATION MAKE US ALL VERY
PROUD EAT THEM AGAIN WE OR WHO
YOUR SOURCE.
THE NINE HONOREES WE HAVE HERE
TODAY REPRESENT THE RICHNESS OF
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSITY AND HOW
THE STATE IS A SANCTUARY FOR
BRILLIANT CREATIVE AND
HARDWORKING PEOPLE.
AND MOST OF THE HONOREES HAVE
ONE THING IN COMMON WITH MYSELF
AND MY MEXICAN IMMIGRANT PARENTS
WE EACH HAVE AT LEAST FIVE TO
TEN JOBS.
WE HAVE AN ARMY VETERAN WHO
SERVED THIS COUNTRY WAS UNJUSTLY
DEPORTED ONLY TO BE PARDONED
FINALLY GRANTED CITIZENSHIP
SURVIVE EIGHT WE HAVE A SURVIVOR
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHO
SURVIVED HER HARROWING ORDEAL.
AND VOWED TO BE THERE TO SUPPORT
AND EMPOWER OTHERS GOING THROUGH
SIMILAR ABUSE.
TWO CATEGORIES HIT MY LIFE MY
MOTHER WAS A SURVIVOR OF
DOMESTIC ABUSE ABUSE.
WE HAVE AN ACTIVISTS FROM A
FAMILY OF FARM WORKERS WHO TOOK
IT UPON HERSELF TO USE
TECHNOLOGY TO REDUCE HEAT STROKE
AMONG FARMWORKERS. WE HAVE A
FAMILY WHOSE PASSION FOR FINE
COFFEE BROUGHT THEM FROM WHO
LEFT TO LA WHERE THEY DECIDE TO
HELP MAKING THE COMMUNITY AS
MUCH A PART OF THEIR FIGHT MEDIA
HAS ARE GREAT CUPS OF CAFE.
WE HAVE TO JOURNALISM TV
PERSONALITIES WHEN YOU USE OUR
PLATFORM TO ADVOCATE FOR THOSE
CARRY AND LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S THE SECOND CATEGORY
THAT AFFECTED ME PERSONALLY MY
MOTHER PASSED AWAY.
THREE YEARS AGO MONEY OTHER HAS
TO SUCK US.
WHO HAD A DIMENSION FOR YEARS?
AND.
I GOT TO HONOR HER BY WORKING
ON THE FILM COCOA.
WHICH I HOPE YOU ALL WENT AND
CRIED.
AND.
WE HAVE ANOTHER.
ANOTHER MATE COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT CENTRAL VALLEY
ESSENTIAL PART OF ROOM BROADCAST
WE HAVE AN ARMY VETERAN WHO
RETURNED FROM SERVICE AND
DEDICATED HIS LIFE.
KIDS FUNDING FOR FARMWORKERS AND
BECOMING A CHAMPION FOR LATINOS
YOU KNOW HE WAS SOMEONE I THINK
THIS AWARD. BESTOWS HIM
HONORARY.
CHICANO STATUS.
NOW WE HAVE A MEXICAN BORDER TO
OURS ELEVATED THE ART FORM OPEN
UP AN INCREDIBLE WORK WORLD
FAMOUSTATTOO PARTNER THAT
LAUNCHED A HUGELY SUCCESSFUL TV
SHOW.
NOW SHE'S USE THAT SUCCESS
ADVOCATE FOR ANIMALS COMMUNITY
IN THE REQUIREMENTS.
WE HAVE AN OVER THE TOP REAL
ESTATE MILLIONAIRE WHO BECAME A
REALITY TV STAR AND THEN RAN FOR
THE HIGHEST OFFICE IN THE LAND.
KIDDING.
SOMEBODY'S LISTENING.
AND FINALLY THE ONLY OTHER
HONOREE FUNNIER THAN MYSELF HA
HA HE'S AN ACTOR DIRECTOR WRITER
MUSICIAN.
AND GARDENING ENTHUSIASTS
WHO CAN BE IDENTIFIED WORLDWIDE.
NOW IS THERE ARE COLLECTOR
HUMANITARIAN WHO'S BECOME THE
GODFATHER OF CHICANO ART IN
CALIFORNIA AND I HOPE HE BUYS
MORE MONEY PIECES.
SOON.
ALL OF THESE HONOREES EVERY
SINGLE ONE. BRING SOMETHING TO
THE TABLE THAT REPRESENTS WHAT
IT MEANS TO BE CALIFORNIA.
THROUGH THEIR WORD CREATIVITY
INGENUITY OR SERVICE THEY MAKE
CALIFORNIA STRONGER AND MORE
BOUNTIFUL. THEY INSPIRE US TO
GROW TO LIVE TO UNDERSTAND AND
RESPECT ONE ANOTHER. AND TO WORK
EVEN HARDER.
AND TO BE DREAMERS.
AND BUILDERS OF BRIDGES AND NOT
WALLS.
HONOREES YOU ALL PERSONIFY WE
CALL THAT THE YOU KNOW SPIRIT
THAT'S WHY I AM PROUD TO STAND
HERE AS A CHICANO ARTISTS.
AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AS WE HONOR
YOU WITH THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN LET
YOU KNOW SPIRIT AWARDS.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU ALL AND
PHILLY SEE THE OTHERS TO THE
LATINO CAUCUS FOR HONORING THESE
WONDERFUL PEOPLE WHO REPRESENT
ELLIS PEOPLE LIKE YOU KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER ABOUT AS.
MEMBERS AS WE CONCLUDE OUR
CEREMONY WE ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU
AND ARE VISITORS IN GAS TO VIEW
THE SPECIAL EXHIBITION WHICH IS
ON THE CAPITAL SECOND FLOOR.
ROTUNDA THESE OUT FEATURES THE
ARTERIES THAT WE HAVEJUST
INTRODUCED EVERYONE.
AND THAT BRINGS US TO THE END
OF THE CEREMONY CAN WE ASK FOR
ONE A FINAL ROUND OF APPLAUSE
FOR ALL OF OUR WORRIES
MEMBERS WERE GONNA RETURN BACK
TO IT INTRODUCTIONS.
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER
AT HER DESK FOR HER
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THE FOURTH GRADERS FROM
LIVE OAK AND
SCHOOL IN SAN.
TODAY.
TODAY THERE FROM THE CLASS OF
ROBERT ALVAREZ THEIR MASCOT IS
THE GOLDEN EAGLE AND THEY HAVE
BEEN RECOGNIZES THE MIX IT UP
MODEL SCHOOL FOR TWENTY SIXTEEN
BY THE SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW
CENTER'S.
TEACHING TOLERANCE PROGRAM FOR
THEIR GREAT EFFORTS TO FOSTER
RESPECT AND UNDERSTANDING AMONG
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE CAMPUS
PLEASE WELCOME OUR STUDENTS FROM
LIVE OAK ELEMENTARY. WELCOME
.
MEMBERS WILL MOVE TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE START WITH THE
SECOND READING.
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY HALL THIRTY FORTY TWO
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN
FORTY TWO TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE SEVENTEEN
NINETY SEVEN WITH THE MOMENT
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TO TWENTY NINE
SIXTY NINE TWENTY THREE THIRTY
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY NINE TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN. THAT'S ON THE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWO TWENTY
TWO YOU WITH AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIX THIRTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS WAY FORTY SEVEN WITH
THE MOMENTS WHEN NINE TWENTY
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS AND TWENTY
FIVE ELEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
TURN TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE UNDER RECONSIDERATION.
ITEMS ON RECONSIDERATION OUR
CONTINUED.
WHICH BRINGS US TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING.
MEMBERS WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON
ITEMS TWENTY FOUR TO TWENTY
SEVEN.
QUICKLY SENATORS ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT.
GREGORY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FIFTY
ONE BY SONY MEMBER GRAIN OTHERS
ACTUALLY TO HUNTING.
TO GRAY ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE IS A
MODEST BUT IMPORTANT BILL TO
ADDRESS.
THE DRAMATIC DECLINE IN THE
NUMBER OF HUNTERS SPECIFICALLY
OUTDOOR SPORTSMAN YOU CONNORS
WOMEN CAL WOMEN HUNTERS. OVER
THE PAST TWENTY YEARS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
IS.
DEPENDING ON THE REVENUES
GENERATED BY OUTDOOR SPORTING
ACTIVITIES TO FUND VITAL
CONSERVATION. EFFORTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IF NUMBER HUNTERS IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO PLUMMET THE
REVENUES TO SUPPORT THESE
PROJECTS WILL CONTINUE TO BE
REDUCED TO NOTHING.
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO MAKE
HUNTING MORE AFFORDABLE FOR USED
TO ENCOURAGE PARTICIPATION AMONG
THE NEXT GENERATION OF HUNTERS.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST BARRIERS FOR
CALIFORNIANS.
INTEREST IN THIS TRADITION IS
UNNECESSARILY HIGH PRICE ABUSED.
BIG GAME TAGS WHERE'S CALIFORNIA
JUNIOR HUNTERS PAY FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS FOR NOW TAG A
YOUTH IN MONTANA COLORADO JPAY
JUST TEN DOLLARS AND SEVENTY
FIVE CENTS.
AB TWENTY ONE OF FIFTY ONE
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS IS DIVIDE BY
GIVING JUNIOR HUNTERS ACCESS TO
LOWER COST TAGS. AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY ONE TO SUPPORT BY THE
CALIFORNIA HUNTING CONSERVATION
COALITION THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF OPERATING ENGINEERS
AMONG OTHERS. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE VOTE
TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER FRANK.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
LOCAL OPEN THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW TO VOTE EYES FORTY NINE
KNOWS ONE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIN ON ITEM TWENTY NINE.
BRINGS US TO AYE A FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JOINT
SO WHERE ACTUALLY CAO FRESH.
JONES SAWYER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT A BE EIGHTEEN
NINETY TO A BILL THAT WOULD
ALLOW AYE STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
TO ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO EXTEND.
TRANSITIONAL CAL FRESH BENEFITS
TO FAMILIES LEAVING LEAVING
STATE AND LOCALLY FUNDED CAST
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WILL
CLARIFY THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
SHOUT ISSUE GUIDE FOR COUNTIES
TO COVER A PORTION OF THE COST
OF HOME INTERNET. OR PHONE
SERVICE FORCE INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVING CAL FRESH EMPLOYMENT
AND TRAINING FUNDS FINALLY JUST
BILL WOULD INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS INDIVIDUALS WITH
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT THAT
COUNTIES MAY SERVE TO.
PARTNERSHIP WOULD EMPLOYMENT
SOCIAL ENTERPRISES
INDIVIDUALS TRANSITIONING OFF
OF CANCER SYSTEM PROGRAM SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THEIR
NEXT MEAL AS THEY ADJUST TO THE
NEW JOBS. JUST BILL WILL WOULD
PROVIDE RELIEF FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS INSURE YOUR
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION INTO THE
WORKPLACE.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOU AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONESSAWYER
MISTER BIGELOW YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS WE HEARD THIS AND
APPROPRIATIONS AND.
THROUGH THE GREAT.
DISTANCE OF THE AUTHOR HE WORKED
WITH MY OFFICE TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS AND THIS.
MAKES A BILL MUCH MORE
SUPPORTABLE SO WOULD ENCOURAGE
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW. SEEN
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM MISTER JONES SAWYER
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
BIGELOW TO OUR SPECS LAST VIVO.
TAKING MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO IS THERE TO
VOTE
.
CLICK A CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW
THE VOTE AYE SIXTY NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIN ON ITEMS THIRTY ONE
THROUGH THIRTY SEVEN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
FIVE BY SOMETHING
COOLEY AND ACTUALLY THE
CANNABIS.
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES AND PLEASE RESENT AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY FIVE RELATED
CANNABIS PLANT TAGGING.
BOTH EMC RSA AND PROP SIXTY
FOUR.
REQUIRES THE COMMERCIAL
CULTIVATION OF CANNABIS
OF BE SEPARATE A TRACK AND TRACE
PROGRAM.
ALLOWS TRACKING CANNABIS FROM
ITS INITIAL CULTIVATION THROUGH
SALE. THIS BILL.
FOLLOWS THE PATTERN OF COLORADO
WASHINGTON WHERE THEY'VE BEEN
DUDES OF PROGRAM FOR SOME TIME.
SAID IN A STANDARD FOR HOW HE'S
TRACKING TREES PROGRAMS WORK
DEBILIS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT MPS BRING IT
HERE AND REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY. MISTER
LACKEY YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
I STAND THE SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
IT WILL STANDARDIZE WERE PLANTS
WILL BE TAGGED IN THE STATE'S
TRACK AND TRACE SYSTEM.
STANDARDIZING THIS WILL ALLOW
THE STATE TO USE ADVANCED
ANALYTICS TO DETECT SUSPICIOUS
ACTIVITY A POTENTIAL DIVERSION
TO THE ILLEGAL MARKET.
THIS NEWPORT CHANGING LA.
I LIKE TO THINK THE MEMBER WHO
FOUNDED THE CITY OF RANCHO
CORDOVA FOR BRING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD NASH WE.
FOR THOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY.
SEEN OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
MISTER COOLEY YOU MAY CLOSE.
THE BILL ENJOYS CRIES OF A
CLAIM.
I'M PLEASED TO BRING YOU HERE
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY A. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
QUICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALAGA VOTE AYE SIXTY SIX KNOW
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
REMOVED A FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY NINE THE COOKERY.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
NINE BY SOMETHING
CABALLERO AND OTHERS AND ACT
LIKE A PHARMACY.
IT'S CAREER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE WHICH
WOULD INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY
OF SAFE STORAGE DEVICES IN
PHARMACIES SO I STICK SECURE
DANGEROUS AND ADDICTIVE.
MEDICATIONS AT HOME.
EVERY YEAR SIXTY THOUSAND
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF FIVE
END UP IN A IN AN EMERGENCY ROOM
BECAUSE THEY SWALLOW DANGEROUS
MEDICATIONS.
EVERY DAY THREE THOUSAND
TEENAGERS ABUSE A PRESCRIPTION
PAINKILLER FOR THE FIRST TIME
AND THE MAJORITY OF TEENS GET
THESE PILLS FROM A HOUSEHOLD
MEDICINE CABINET.
THIS IS BECAUSE VERY FEW
HOUSEHOLDS LOCKED UP
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION. THE
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL HAS
REPORTED THAT ONLY THREE PERCENT
OF HOMES ACTUALLY DO. TO GET IT
TO GET AHEAD OF THIS OPIOID
EPIDEMIC A CRITICAL FOCUS IS
PREVENTION TO HELP SECURE PAIN
KILLERS TO ENSURE RESPONSIBLE
USE.
AND CHILD SAFETY.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE WILL
REQUIRE PHARMACIES TO CARRY SAFE
STORAGE DEVICES WITH A FINANCIAL
HEARTS SHIP EXCEPTION FOR
SMALLER PHARMACIES.
THIS WILL EDUCATE PARENTS ABOUT
SECURE STORAGE AND PREVENT
ACCIDENTAL INGESTION AND CURIOUS
EXPERIMENTATION BY CHILDREN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU MISS COLLIER.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
THE THING Y. SE BEFORE WE TAKE
THE VOTE.
NOW MISTER SPEAKER.
YEAH WHO CLICK LOVE IN THE
WORLD.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES IFES FIFTY SIX
KNOWS SIX.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
PASSING RETAIN ON ITEMS FORTY TO
FORTY FOUR.
BRINGS US TO A FILE ITEM FORTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL THIRTY THIRTY SIX BY
FAMILY MEMBER COOLEY AND
ACTUALLY THE SOLID WASTE.
MISTER COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES AND PLEASE RESENT AB
THIRTY THIRTY SIX THIS IS A
MEASURE DEALING WITH THE
DEFINITION OF SOLID WASTE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW FOOD
PROCESSING BYPRODUCTS.
I CAN TRIGGER LICENSURE IN
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS UNDER
LOCAL FRANCHISE.
.
LAWS CONCERNING THE REMOVAL OF
OF WASTE.
A.
THE FACT THAT FOOD WASTE CAN BE
THAT'S CLASSIFIED PUTS A BURDEN
ON AGRICULTURE PRODUCERS.
WHO MIGHT OTHERWISE COLLECT THIS
IN NEWSIES PARSON FEED FOR THEIR
ANIMALS?
DIVERTED FROM LANDFILLS.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU HERE ON
THE FOR THE WASTE HAULING AND
REMOVAL FRANCHISES INDUSTRY WHO
WORK WITH ME ON THIS BILL. TO
OUR.
IDENTIFY IN A WRITTEN FORMAT
ALLOWS THIS PRODUCT.
TO BE DIVERTED FROM THE WASTE
STREAM PUT TO GOOD USE.
AND IS COMPATIBLE WITH EXISTING
FRANCHISE AGREEMENT
A. AYE URGENT AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL TO SUPPORT OUR AG SECTOR. A
RE UC'S PRODUCTS.
.
AND KEEP IT OUT OF THE LANDFILL.
ORIGINALLY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY. SEEN
OTHER MEMBERS THAT WISH TO SPEAK
ON THIS MEASURE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY THREE
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
IT'S BEEN JUST I I FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY SIX.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE
EIGHTY BY SOME A MEMBER WALDRON
RELATIVE TO MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH AWARENESS MY.
SOME A MEMBER WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AS A MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I'M PRESENTING
ACR ONE EIGHTY WHICH DEDICATES
THE MONTH OF MAY AS MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH.
ETERNAL MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS
ENCOMPASS A RANGE OF CONDITIONS
WITH VARYING SEVERITY INCLUDING
DEPRESSION ANXIETY DISORDERS AND
POSTPARTUM PSYCHOSIS.
MATERNAL DEPRESSION IS THE MOST
COMMON.
COMPLICATION OF PREGNANCY AND
CHILDBIRTH THAT WOMEN IN THE
UNITED STATES FACE TODAY.
ALL WOMEN ARE AT RISK OF
SUFFERING FROM MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS.
TWENTY PERCENT OF EXPECTANT
MOTHERS WILL EXPERIENCE A MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDER DURING
PREGNANCY.
AND IF LEFT UNTREATED MENTAL
HEALTH COMPLICATIONS CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY AND NEGATIVELY
IMPACT THE SHORT AND LONG TERM
HEALTH AND WELL BEING. OF
AFFECTED WOMEN AND THEIR
CHILDREN.
DESPITE THESE CONSEQUENCES
SCREENING FORM OF MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS IS NOT
ROUTINE ACROSS HEALTH SYSTEMS
AND EVEN WHEN. DETECTED ONLY
FIFTEEN PERCENT OF WOMEN ARE
TREATED.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE
RECOGNIZE MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS AND END THE
STIGMATIZATION OF THESE
DISORDERS. THROUGH EDUCATION AND
ALSO ENCOURAGING WOMEN AND
FAMILIES TO SEEK TREATMENT I
ALSO THE FIRST ROLE WE OPEN FOR
COAUTHORS AND I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM AND MISS
WALDRON IS ASKING FOR CO AUTHORS
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE.
MEMBERS THIS IS COOPERS ON THIS
MEASURE.
THIS RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
MEASURE HAS SIXTY A CO AUTHORS.
WE NOW TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THIS.
I DON'T ALL MEMBERS.
IN FAVOR SAY AYE HIGH ANY
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THAT IS ADOPTED.
SPRINGS THE FILE ITEM FORTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TILL NINE BY SOMEONE.
AIKMAN MELTED
COMPOST AWARENESS WE.
THIS EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS THAT EVERY DAY WE TALK
ABOUT COMPOSTING BUT TODAY'S THE
DAY AS WE STAND HERE ON THE
GREEN CARPET AND REFLECT ON OUR
HISTORY OF AGRICULTURE. AND
BEING OF THE EARTH I PRESENT TO
YOU ACR TWO OH NINE.
ALSO THE AREA CODE FOR THE
VALLEY.
HAD TO YEARS AGO WE ARE PASSIN
AMBITIOUS BILL OF DIVERTING
THREE QUARTERS OF OUR ORGANIC
WASTE TO LANDFILLS TO HIRE A
BETTER USES IN ORDER TO REDUCE
THE STATE'S METHANE. ORGANIC
MATERIALS MAKE UP A THIRD STILL
OF WHAT WE PUT INTO LANDFILLS
COMPOSTING PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE
IN BEING ABLE TO ADD A DRESS
THAT.
FANTASTIC DATA ON CARBON
SEQUESTRATION ON BEING ABLE TO
GET OUT OF OUR LAND FEEL BACK TO
GROWING OUR PLANTS AND MAKING
OUR STATE RICH A WE KNOW AS
EVERYONE TO SAID WE ARE THE NOW
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
UNITED STATES AND PART OF THAT
COMES FROM OUR. OUR OF POLICIES
THAT DRIVE US IN AGAIN AS WE
STAND ON THIS GREEN CARPET AND
WE RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
AGRICULTURE THE HISTORY
COMPOSTING WE ARE OF THE EARTH
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON ACR TWO OH NINE AS WE
CELEBRATE. COMPOSTING AND PUT UP
SIGNS ON ALL OUR OFFICE DOORS.
THANK YOU MS EGGMAN ARE YOU
REQUESTING CO AUTHORS OF THE
WITH RESOLUTION VERY A.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM I MISS EGGMAN
IS ASKING FOR A CO AUTHORS THE
CLERK WILL OPEN.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SIXTY NINE CO
AUTHORS.
WE CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE
SAY AYE AYE. ANY OPPOSED SAY
NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
QUICK PLEASE READ ON ITEM FORTY
EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO EIGHTEEN BY SOMEONE
OBERNOLTE RELATIVE TO LYME
DISEASE AWARENESS.
MR OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT.
ACR TO EIGHTEEN WHICH TOOK WOULD
DECLARE THE MONTH OF MAY HAS
LYME DISEASE AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA. LYME DISEASE IS A
DEBILITATING BACTERIAL INFECTION
THAT IS SPREAD BY THE BITE OF AN
INFECTED TECH.
I'D THE CDC ESTIMATES THAT OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND NEW CASES OF
LYME WILL BE DIAGNOSED THIS YEAR
IN THE UNITED STATES. AND ALSO
ACCORDING TO THE CDC. UP TO
NINETY PERCENT OF NEW LUNG
DISEASE CASES REMAIN UNDIAGNOSED
WHICH SUGGESTS THAT THE TRUE
NUMBER OF LIME DISEASE CASES IN
THE UNITED STATES EXCEEDS THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PER YEAR.
THIS DISEASE IS ALSO AN ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA IT
SPREAD THROUGH THE BITE OF THE
BLACK Y. GOOD.
TECH WITCHES INDIGENOUS TO
FIFTY SIX OR FIFTY OF THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA SO
IT'S VERY MUCH AN ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA.
ONE DISEASE IS INCREDIBLY HARD
TO DIAGNOSE AN INCREDIBLY HARD
TO TREAT. AND MEMBERS I HAVE
SOME PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH
THIS DISORDER THERE'S A MEMBER
OF MY CAPITAL STAFF THERE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH LYME SEVERAL
YEARS AGO AND I HAVE BEEN
ASTONISHED. AT HOW DIFFICULT
THIS DISEASE IS TO TREAT. BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY HOW
DEBILITATING IT CAN BE FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO SUFFER FROM IT SO I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE YOUR I VOTE ON ACR TO
EIGHTEEN. MISTER SPEAKER I WOULD
REQUEST THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN
FOR COAUTHORS.
BIGGEST OBERNOLTE SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WISH TO SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR
COOPER.
MEMBERS THIS IS PRO CO AUTHORS.
ON ACR TO EIGHTEEN.
THERE ARE SEVENTY CO AUTHORS.
WE CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
I.
THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED MISTER OBERNOLTE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE MEMBERS OF
THE SACRAMENTO LINESUPPORT
GROUP OF COME TO THE CAPITOL
TODAY TO HELP RAISE AWARENESS OF
LYME DISEASE.
THIS GROUP HELPS TO BRING
ATTENTION TO THE NEED FOR BETTER
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT OF LYME
DISEASE AND ALSO OFFER SUPPORT
TO INDIVIDUALS FIGHTING THIS
DISEASE. COLLEGE PLEASE JOIN ME
IN GIVING THEM A WARM ASSEMBLY
WELCOME.
HOW?
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN UP FILE ITEM
FORTY NINE WILL PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM FIFTY. TO BRING THE
STUFF FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
ONE BY SOME A MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
AND ACTUALLY TO THE MILITARY.
SIMILAR QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AS WE SEND OUR GUARD MEMBERS OFF
FOR DUTY. AND AS WE LOOK AT
MAKING SURE THEY'RE SERVING OUR
COUNTRY MANY TIMES WE REALIZE
THAT OUR TECHNOLOGY HAS NOT
CAUGHT UP. WITH.
THAT REQUIREMENTS THAT WE ASK
THEM TO DO SO THIS A LOT WOULD
ADAM WOULD WORK TOWARDS OUR
SERVICE MEMBERS WHO ARE
REQUESTING DEFERMENT OF
APPLICABLES LOANS AB TWO FIVE
TWO ONE THE CALIFORNIA. MILITARY
FAMILIES FINANCIAL RELIEF ACT
PROTECTS RESERVISTS WHO
ARE CALLED UPON TO SERVE OUR
STATE AND NATION.
PLAMEN IS A TIME WHEN MILITARY
RESERVISTS SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON
THEIR FAMILIES AS THEY PREPARE
TO LEAVE AND PER.
PAIRING FOR THEIR MISSION THEY
SHOULD NOT BE FOCUSING ON FILING
PAPERS.
AB FOR TWO FIVE TWO ONE WILL
REMOVE THE PHRASE UNDER PENALTY
OF PERJURY AS WELL AS.
PLACE THE PHRASE LETTER SIGNED
WITH A WRITTEN REQUEST IN THE
MILITARY VETERANS PODE.
WE SIMPLY WANT TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR OUR MEMBERS TO PREPARE TO
LEAVE AND TO SERVE OUR COUNTRY
THE LAW WOULD PROTECT THE MEN
AND THE WOMEN THAT STEP UP AND
SUPPORT OUR COUNTRY. AND THE
CALIFORNIA DISASTER RELIEF AND
EMERGENCY SERVICES WITHOUT
READING THE LAW MANY DO NOT KNOW
ABOUT THE REQUIREMENT.
TO.
FIX THIS UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY SO WITH THIS IT'S JUST A
SIMPLE UPDATE AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
MAKING HIS QUIRK SILVA.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY KNOWS
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
IT'S CALDERON YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER FOR
ROUGH MOTIONS I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES TO TAKE
UP. SCR ONE THIRTY FOUR GALGIANI
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MISTER ROGERS.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR GALGIANI
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA PEACE.
MEMORIAL DAY.
CERVANTES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY
I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY
FOUR BY SENATOR GALGIANI.
I C. ARE WHEN THIRTY FOUR
DESIGNATES TODAY MAY SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS
CALIFORNIA'S PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL DAY.
ON THIS DAY WE HONOR THE PEACE
OFFICERS WHO TRAGICALLY LOST
THEIR LIVES IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
ENSURING THE SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES IS ONE OF THE
PRIORITIES OF OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT AND OUR PEACE
OFFICERS ARE ON THE GROUND EVERY
DAY SERBIAN DOT A VITAL PURPOSE.
FOR MORE THAN FORTY YEARS OUR
STATE HAS COMMEMORATED PEACE
OFFICERS MEMORIAL DAY IN ORDER
TO HONOR THESE HEROES WHO GAVE
THEIR LIVES WHILE SAFEGUARDING
OUR COMMUNITIES.
TODAY WE RECOGNIZE SIX OFFICERS
WHO LOST THEIR LIVES IN THE LINE
OF DUTY AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
THEY ARE.
OFFICER KEITH W. BOYER.
WHITTIER POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
OF WATCH FEBRUARY TWENTIETH
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
OFFER SIR LUCAS F. GELU
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL AND OF
WATCH FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
DEPUTY SHERIFF JASON A GARDENER.
STANISLAUS COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND OF WATCH MAY
THIRTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
DEPUTY SHERIFF ROBERT P.
RUMSFELD LAKE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND OF WATCH AUGUST
TWENTY SECOND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
DEPUTY SHERIFF ROBERT A FRENCH
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
pTHIRTIETH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
OFFICER ANDREW J. CAMEL LARRY
SENIOR CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
AND OF WATCH DECEMBER TWENTY
FOURTH TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE TO PEACE
OFFICERS WHO LOST THEIR LIVES IN
THE LINE OF DUTY IN PRIOR YEARS.
BUT HAVE NOT BEEN AND ROLLED
YET.
OFFICER MURRAY AFTER ALL SEN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND OF WATCH MARCH
NINTH NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
OFFICER LUIS ALISON LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND
OF WATCH MARCH TWENTY SEVENTH
NINETEEN FIFTEEN.
I JOIN WITH THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA IN MOURNING THE LOSS
OF THESE BRAVE PEACE OFFICERS
WILL KEEP THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN OUR PRAYERS.
I AM HUMBLED BY THE DEVOTION OF
THESE OFFICER SHOWED FOR THE
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY SERVE AS WELL AS OUR
WILLINGNESS TO SACRIFICE
THEMSELVES FOR OUR GREAT STATE.
MISTER SPEAKER.
I SEE ARE ONE THIRTY FOUR
AFFORDS US WITH THE NECESSARY
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO THESE PEACE
OFFICERS WHO GAVE THE LAST FULL
MEASURE OF DEVOTION.
TO MAKE CALIFORNIA A SAFER PLACE
TO LIVE AND RAISE OUR FAMILIES
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CERVANTES.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL REQUEST TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTES I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO. THE MEASURES ADOPTED.
MUSIC RETURNING TO THE DAILY
FILE WILL GO TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
TWO.
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO THIRTY
SEVEN BY SOMETHING THAT
CHINA AND I.
OPERATION.
MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THINK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY SEVEN WILL
REQUIRE CORPORATIONS THAT
CORPORATE IN CALIFORNIA TO MAKE
A TRUE COPY OF THEIR RECORDS
AVAILABLE TO SHAREHOLDERS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO ALLOW THE
SHAREHOLDER TO REQUEST THE
CORPORATION TO PRODUCE THE
RECORDS BY MAIL OR
ELECTRONICALLY.
IF THE SHAREHOLDER PAYS FOR
REASONABLE COST THIS WILL REMOVE
THE BURDEN OF CALIFORNIAN*
TRAVELING ACROSS STATE LINES TO
ACCESS BOOKS AND RECORDS.
THEY CAN I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU MR MAIENSCHEIN THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL REQUEST TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THE VOTES I SEVENTY NO ZERO
MEASURE.
IS ADOPTED.
IT TURNED OUT TO ITEM FIFTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY SEVENTY THREE
BY FAMILY MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY NEEDS.
CHOOSE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB
TWENTY SEVENTY THREE WOULD
PROTECT HOMEOWNERS FROM
POTENTIALLY FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS
ON THE PART OF THREE DEFENDANTS.
IN A LEAD PAINT JUDGMENT UPHELD
BY AN APPELLATE COURT LATE LAST
YEAR. THERE WERE TWO SENTENCES
IN A ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
PAGE DECISION THAT SUGGESTED
THAT THE THREE LEAD PAINT
MANUFACTURER DEFENDANTS MIGHT
SUE HOMEOWNERS FOR THE COST TO
ABATE LEAD PAINT IN THEIR HOMES.
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS THAT WOULD
DISCOURAGE HOMEOWNERS FROM
PARTICIPATING IN A PROGRAM TO
CLEAN UP LEAD PAINT DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THESE DEFENDANTS WERE
FOUND TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
HEALTH HAZARDS. OF SELLING LEAD
PAINT THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION I WANT TO THANK BOTH
SIDES OF THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FOR THE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
COMMITTEE. AS WELL AS FOR THE
SUPPORT OF ORGANIZATIONS FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH CARE
CONSUMERS FAMILIES AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WITH THAT RESPECT WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
SPEAK ON THIS MATTER SO WE WILL
ASK THE CLERK TO OPEN THE
ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLIED
THE VOTE ITEMS I SEVENTY NO
ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES.
YOU PASS RETAIN ON A FILE ITEMS
FIFTY FOUR.
TWO SIXTY FIVE.
WHICH MEANS TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
SIX
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
ONE BY SOME REMEMBER BURKE AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE HEALING
ARTS.
SIMILAR BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER EIGHT
AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY ONE IS A BIPARTISAN
MEASURE THAT SETS A FIVE DAY
LIMIT ON IT WILL BE EIGHT
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR ACUTE PAIN
MANAGEMENT FOR MINORS. WITH THE
EXCEPTION FOR CHRONIC PAIN
MANAGEMENT HOSPICE PALLIATIVE
CARE AND CANCER PATIENTS
MINOR UNDER TREATMENT FOR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS AND IN
CASE OF EMERGENCIES.
THINK MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN A SUPPORT
OF AMENDED POSITION AND WE'VE
AGREED TO TAKE THOSE AMENDMENTS
IN DOING SO WILL BE REMOVING THE
REQUIREMENT FOR A WRITTEN
CONSENT AND INSTEAD PROVIDING
GUIDELINES FOR INFORMED CONSENT.
WITH THE INFORMATION NOTED IN
THE PATIENT'S MEDICAL RECORDS.
THE SECOND LARGEST GROUPS OF
PRESCRIBERS IS THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION WHO HAS
AGREED TO THE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
TAKING AND IS A SORE PORT
POSITION AS WELL.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY ONE DOES
NOT USURP A PROVIDERS DISCRETION
A PHYSICIAN CAN'T PRESCRIBE MORE
THAN FIVE DAYS IF YOU'RE SHE
FELT IT WAS MEDICALLY NECESSARY.
BY SIMPLY NOTATING THE FILE.
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
RELATE RELATED UPDATED
GUIDELINES IN JULY OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OR MAKE
RECOMMENDING NO MORE THAN A
THREE DAY PRESCRIPTION FOR ACUTE
PAIN MANAGEMENT.
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
SPECIFICALLY RECOMMENDS OPIOIDS
FOR PAIN FOR PAIN IN MINORS ONLY
AFTER NON OPIOID ALTERNATIVES
HAVE FAILED.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD TAKE THE
CONCEPT OF BIRDS PRESCRIPTION
LIMIT LATELY HOWEVER I BELIEVE
THERE ARE CERTAIN PROBLEMS THAT
REQUIRE SWIFT AND EXCEPTIONAL
LEGISLATIVE RESPONSE.
ACCORDING TO A MARCH TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN STUDY BY THE
CDC. LONG* OPIOID VIEWS
OFTEN BEGINS WITH TREATMENT OF
ACUTE PAIN.
THE PROBABILITY OF LONG TERM
OPIOID USE INCREASES MOST
SHARPLY IN THE FIRST DAYS OF
THERAPY ESPECIALLY AFTER FIVE
DAYS.
BY JULY TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
TWENTY THREE OTHER STATES HAVE
ENACTED LEGISLATION WITH SOME
TYPE OF LIMIT GUIDANCE OR
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO OPIOID
PRESCRIBING.
AS A RESULT THEY HAVE SECRET
SEEN A DECREASE IN ABUSE.
MEANWHILE IN OUR STATE THERE ARE
COUNTIES WHERE PRESCRIPTION
RATES AND ABUSE ARE RISING
DAILY.
WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF THE WORST
DRUG ADDICTION EPIDEMIC IN
UNITED STATES HISTORY.
BUT WE ARE STILL CONTINUING TO
MASSIVELY OVER PRESCRIBED.
IT CAN TAKE UP TO TEN YEARS FOR
ANY NEW RECOMMENDATIONS TO
BECOME COMMON PRACTICE.
THIS EPIDEMIC IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
NINETY ONE TO US EVERY DAY.
FORTY TWO OF THOSE ARE FROM
PRESCRIBED OPIOIDS
WHEN IT COMES TO CHILDREN WE DO
NOT HAVE THE LUXURY TO WAIT TEN
YEARS I RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS
AND I'VE.
BANKING IS BURKE.
SUDAHLAH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE ALSO.
AS A CO AUTHOR TO THIS BILL AND
A.
I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR A
REACHING OUT AS YOU KNOW I MEAN
A VERY RULE DISTRICT AND.
WE HAVE.
MANY MILES TO GET TO A PHARMACY
IN SOME CASES IT MY OWN CASE AS
A FIFTY MILES ONE WAY.
TALK TO MY COUSIN WHO IS A
MEDICAL DOCTOR. WHO RECOMMENDED
THAT THIS IS A GOOD PIECE OF
LEGISLATION OPIOID ABUSE AND
ADDICTION IS VERY HIGH?
IN MY DISTRICT IS IN IN AND
SHASTA COUNTY ONE OF THE HIGHEST
PLACES IN THE NATION. AND OUT WE
KNOW THAT'S A STATISTIC SHOW
THAT AT THE LONGER YOU PRESCRIBE
THE MORE LIKELY YOU ARE TO BE
ADDICTED IN THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE.
A PIECE OF LEGISLATION AYE
ENCOURAGING AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DOWLING.
MISTER WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I TO RISE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR WORKING
WITH THAT THE STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED AND AND I WOULD PREFER
TO SEE A LITTLE LESS
PRESCRIPTIVE APPROACH. HOWEVER
THE SPIRIT IN WHICH IS BEING
PRESENTED THE WORK SHE'S
CONTINUED TO DO TO DO ON THIS ON
THIS ISSUE THIS CRITICAL ISSUE.
I APPLAUD YOUR EFFORTS AND I'M
I'M PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
WORKING.
TO MAKE IT A BETTER BILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD. SOMEONE
NUMBER LOVE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THE WORK ON THIS BILL
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH FOUNDATION AT THEIR
ENOUGH OPIOIDS EVER PRESCRIBED
IN ONE SINGLE YEAR FOR EVERY MAN
WOMAN AND CHILD TO BE MEDICATED.
AROUND THE CLOCK FOR AN ENTIRE
MONTH OF THIS GOES TO SHOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE ISSUES.
SUPPORTING OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS OUR CHILDREN AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOVE.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK MS BURKE WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE. AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON ON THIS BILL TO MAKE IT
THE BEST BILL POSSIBLE HOWEVER
MAINTAINING THE PROTECTIONS FOR
OUR MINERS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST NAY VOTE.
MAKING HIS BURKE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
GO.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY THREE
NO ZERO. AND MEASURE PASSES.
WE'LL PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
SIXTY SEVEN.
THROUGH SEVENTY ONE.
SHE BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY TWO.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
S. ON THE CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
NINETY BY SOME
SALAS ABILITY TO BOOST OUR
MOTHERS OF AMERICAN.
MISTER SALAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE PRESENT ACR ONE
NINETY WHICH RECOGNIZES
CONTRIBUTIONS A BLUE STAR
MOTHERS AND PROCLAIMS. MAYORS
BLUESTAR MOTHERS OF AMERICA
MONTH IN CALIFORNIA.
THE REFERENCE TO THE BLUE STAR
DATES BACK TO WORLD WAR ONE.
WHEN MEANT MULLIN MILITARY
FAMILIES WOULD HANG THE SERVICE
FLAG IN THEIR WINDOWS.
AB BLUESTAR DISPLAYED FOR EVERY
LIVING FAMILY MEMBER IN THE
SERVICE.
BLUESTAR MOTHERS ARE THE LARGEST
AND FASTEST GROWING MILITARY
FAMILY ORGANIZATION IN THE
COUNTRY AND IS INSPIRED MORE
THAN TWENTY SIX MILLION HOURS OF
VOLUNTEER SERVICE NATIONWIDE.
WE HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
FOR THOSE FAMILIES HONOR THEIR
LOVED ONES.
FOR SERVING OUR COUNTRY OUR
SERVICE MEMBERS VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES INSPIRES EVERY
DAY EVERY MOMENT. THROUGH THEIR
POISE AND RESILIENCE AND
DESERVE.
ALL OVER RECOGNITION AND
SUPPORT.
ANCHORAGE ALL OF YOU TO REACH
OUT TO YOU BLUESTAR MOTHERS
DURING THE NEXT MONTH TO
RECOGNIZE AND HONOR THEIR
COURAGE AND DEDICATION.
PROTECTING THIS COUNTRY UP
MEMBERS I CAN JUST TELL YOU
PERSONALLY HIVE.
INTERACT WITH MY LOCAL CHAPTER
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS NOW.
AND THERE'S NOTHING THAT THEY
WON'T DO TO PUT THEIR FAMILIES
FIRST AND TO HELP THOSE.
THAT ARE EITHER DEPLOYED ACROSS
THE COUNTRY OVERSEAS THAT'S
EVERYTHING FROM CARE PACKAGES A
RIGHT NOW WE'RE LOOKING TO
RECOGNIZE THEM ONE OF MY LARGE
CITIES WITH BANNERS UP AND DOWN
THE ANTI RIGHT ALONG. THE
ACTUAL.
A MEMORIAL
BUT.
IF YOU HAVEN'T REACHED OUT YOUR
LOCAL CHAPTERS IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO REACH OUT TO YOUR LOCAL
CHAPTERS PLEASE CONTACT THEM
CONTACT MY OFFICE OF WHICH
SHOULD.
AND CONNECTION TO SEE WHERE YOUR
LOCAL CHAPTERS ARE THESE ARE THE
FOLKS THESE ARE THE MOMS THAT
ARE DEDICATED. TO ALL MILITARY
FAMILIES I THINK THEY ADOPT
EVERYBODY THAT'S JUST NOT THEIR
OWN CHILDREN BUT THEY ADOPT
EVERYBODY TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE AS COMFORTABLE TO KNOW THAT
THEY ARE LOVED.
DOING THEIR DUTY AND THEIR
SERVICE TO PLUCK ALL OF US HERE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK OF THE
FIRST WILL BE OPENED FOR
COAUTHORS. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND THEN I WILL RECOGNIZE OUR
GUESTS.
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS MISTER
CONSTANT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF ACR ONE NINETY. EYES A GOLD
STAR FATHER I PRE SHE'D
EVERYTHING OUR BLUESTAR MOTHERS
DO ON MY SISTER CURRENTLY IS A
BLUE STAR MOTHER AS WELL. AND.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU DO
FOR YOUR CHILDREN BUT ALSO FOR
THE REST OF THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE YOURSELF SUPPORT OF OF.
THOSE OF US.
THAN FORTUNATE OR GOLD STAR
PARENTS ABOUT REACH OUT AS US
AND REMEMBER FROM.
.
BAKERSFIELD KERN COUNTY SAID.
THAT YOU MAKE SURE THAT IF WE
DO APPRECIATE IT IF YOU WOULD
REACH OUT TO THOSE FOLKS IN THE
BLUE STAR MOTHERS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE CHILDREN SERVING.
ARE AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THEY KNOW THAT THEIR HONORED AND
RESPECTED AND THAT THERE NEVER
FORGOTTEN SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I. COURAGE AND I DON'T
THINK.
THANK YOU MISTER COSTER.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS WISH TO
SPEAK ON THE SIDE OF HIS HOUSE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
HOUSE FOR THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN
FOR COST THERE'S A RESPECTFULLY
ASPIRIN I'VE.
NEVER IS MISTER SALAS IS ASKING
FOR AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE.
MEMBERS THIS IS PRO CO AUTHORS.
ON ACR ONE NINETY.
THERE ARE SEVENTY TWO CO
AUTHORS.
CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
HIGH.
THE THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT IN THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
JUST US HERE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS IT'S A
PLEASURE FOR ME TO RECOGNIZE IN
ATTENDANCE TODAY THE KERN RIVER
BLUESTAR MOMS FROM KERN COUNTY.
WE HAVE WITH US AND TO TO PRICE
LIVE YEAH I'M A COST RHONDA OR
TO LENIENT CRISTINA.
KARBALA CARBALLO.
SO PLEASE WELCOME THEM TO THE
FLOOR AND PLEASE REACH OUT TO
THE CRICKET
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS THIS BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE OH FIVE BY
SOME THE NUMBER OF DONALD
RELATIVE TO THE DAY OF THE
TEACHER.
MEMBERS ASKING GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MISTER O'DONNELL.
MISTER DAHLE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
HR ONE OH FIVE WHICH PROCLAIMS
MAY NINTH. AS THE DAY OF THE
TEACHER.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE THE
TIME TO APPRECIATE AND HONOR
THOSE WHO SHARE THE GIFT OF
KNOWLEDGE. THROUGH TEACHING.
BY SHAPING AND GUIDING
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS TEACHERS ARE
CRUCIAL IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
OUR VIBRANT CULTURE. AND BOOMING
ECONOMY.
AS A LONGTIME TEACHER I AM I AM
PROUD TO WORK ALONGSIDE SO MANY
REMARKABLE EDUCATORS WHO ARE
DEDICATED TO OUR STUDENTS INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE. OF THE CLASSROOM.
FIRST RIGHT UP FIRST RECOGNIZE
IN CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE DAY OF THE TEACHER
HONORS CALIFORNIA TEACHERS FOR
THEIR COMMITMENT TO EDUCATING.
OUR CHILDREN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR
TEACHERS.
AND THANK THEM FOR ALL THEY DO
FOR OUR CHILDREN EVERY DAY IN
AND OUT OF THE CLASSROOM.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL. ME
LOOKING FOR CO AUTHORS ON YOUR
RESOLUTION.
HE IS LOOKING FOR COOPER IS ON
HIS RESOLUTION.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL REQUEST TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM AND ASK THE
CLERK TO OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON HR ONE OH FIVE.
THERE ARE SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS.
WE CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MR DARYA RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
DEDUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
.
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
NICK EMAIL OF SK I HOPE I SAID
THAT CORRECTLY SHE IS A SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST AND WE DID HAVE A
SECOND GRADE TEACHER THAT HAD TO
RUN OFF.
BUT I THINK HER FOR BEING HERE
SHE IS WITH THE SACRAMENTO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
SOMEWHERE UP THERE THEN THEY ARE
BOTH OF THEM.
BUT THERE IS A.
THEY ALSO DAVID FISHER DAVID
TEACHES SECOND GRADE HERE IN
SAN.
THANK YOU BOTH.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL.
MOVING TO SENATE THIRD READING
WHERE FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR AT
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL SIX SO SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE MEMBER
RUBIO.
MS RUBIO ON THE MINUTES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO
S. B. SIX ALL SIX
WHICH MAKES WATER OFFENSIVE
EFFICIENCY A WAY OF LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS CONCLUDES A LONG
NEGOTIATION THE BEGAN LAST YEAR
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
WATER AGENCIES AND MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
TOGETHER.
TODAY WE HAD LANGUAGE CLARIFIED
THE EFFICIENCY STANDARDS FOR
LANDSCAPING AS WELL AS
COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
CUSTOMERS.
AND IMPORTANTLY WE'RE ADDING
ADDITIONAL INCENTIVES FOR EARLY
ADOPTERS OF WATER RECYCLING
TECHNOLOGY.
EXISTING PART OF POSSIBLY RE USE
PROJECTS THOSE WITH A CERTIFIED
III ARE BY ONE ONE NINETEEN AND
OPERATIONAL BY ONE ONE TWENTY
TWO WILL GET A FIFTEEN PERCENT
BONUS INCENTIVE.
PROJECTS AFTER THAT DATE WILL
GET A TEN PERCENT BONUS.
BUT THAT FIFTEEN PERCENT CREDIT
IS MEANT TO CAPTURE GROUND
BREAKING PROJECTS LIKE THE
GROUND WATER REPLENISHMENT
SYSTEM IN ORANGE COUNTY AS WELL
AS LONG PLANNED AND FINANCED
PROJECTS LIKE PURE WATER. THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO WHICH WILL GO
ONLINE IN A FEW YEARS.
THIS POLICY HAS MOVED A LONG WAY
IN THE LAST YEAR.
THE AUTHOR HAS LISTEN TO OUR
CONCERNS AND HE HAS BEEN A
PARTNER IN THIS EFFORT.
TODAY I AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ON THE AMENDMENTS
A WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE THOSE OPPOSED
SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED.
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT BACK ON
FIVE.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE TAKE UP THE
CONSENT AGENDA WE WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE.
OVER THE WEEKEND SUMMIT EVER
SURE SHARON QUIRK SILVA AS.
DAUGHTER WAS LAGGED WITH MARY.
CONGRATULATE SHARON ON
.
MOVING TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE A
MY ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR. AT SOME LEGAL
TWENTY SIX SIX
BEFORE BY FAMILY MEMBER HOLDEN
AND ACTUALLY THE COURT
REPORTERS.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE SEVENTY NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
CLIP OF THE THEIR MAIN ISLANDS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY.
I SEVENTY KNOWS.
NONE CYNICAL TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
AYE SEVENTY NO ZERO ILLEGAL
TWENTY SEVEN
TO I SEVENTY NO ZERO CYNICAL
THIRTY SIXTY SIX.
I SEVENTY KNOW ZERO AND ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY TO FORTY EIGHT HIGH
SEVENTY NO ZERO.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
WILL NOW MOVE TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS FOR
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY FOR NEW WALLACE
IT JOURNALISTS A BUSINESSMAN A
FAMILY MAN AND A GOOD FRIEND TO
SO MANY.
NEW PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF
NINETY NINE ON EASTER SUNDAY
SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY.
NEWT MADE A CAREER NEWSPAPERS
THAT LASTED NEARLY SEVENTY YEARS
WORKING FOR DAILIES IN LOS
ANGELES BEFORE BUYING THE
WINTERS EXPRESS IN NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN.
THE WINNERS EXPRESSES THE WEEKLY
NEWSPAPER EVERY THURSDAY
RELIABLY IT WOULD SHOW UP AT MY
DOORSTEP.
CALLED HIMSELF THE WORLD'S
OLDEST PAPERBOY. DELIVERING
PAPER INTO HIS NINETIES EVEN
AFTER HIS RETIREMENT.
AND YOU CAN BE ASSURED THAT
AFTER HE DID HIS PAPER ROUTE HIS
SHOW UP THE BUCKHORN RESTAURANT
AND ASK FOR A COLD OLYMPIA BEER.
NEW IS ACTIVE IN POLITICS AND
EVEN MET.
SEVEN UNITED STATES PRESIDENTS.
WITH ONE OF HIS MOST MEMORABLE
MOMENTS BANG LUNCH AT THE WHITE
HOUSE WITH PRESIDENT KENNEDY.
AND NOT PICTURES OUT OVER HIS
DESK AND STILL WILL BE.
THE MOOD WINTERS EXPRESSES AN
UNIQUE LITTLE TOWN NEWSPAPER
WHICH I LOVE AND I ADMIRE ALL
THE WORK THE WALLACE FAMILY HAS
DONE FOR THIS PAPER.
IT'S FUN TO OPEN UP THAT PAPER
AND SEE WHO THE FUTURE
SUBSCRIBERS ARE. WHAT THE WITH A
LAKE BERRYESSA THAT WATER LEVEL
WOULD BE?
HAVING THE RAIN FELL COMP OF
RAINFALL COMPETITION. WONDERING
ABOUT THE POLICE AND FIRE
REPORTS AND WHO WAS BUSTED AND
WHO WENT TO THE HOSPITAL.
WHAT DO YOU WHO WERE AT THE
LATEST OBITUARIES OVER BEING
FILLED OUT ON THE PAPER?
HE COVERED ALL THE SCHOOL
ACTIVITIES AND EVERY WEDNESDAY
AFTER YOU GOT DONE YOU GO HALVES
BEER.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS CHILDREN
WILSON POKE.
JOHN JAMES CHARLES AND LOIS.
HE HAD NINE GRANDCHILDREN AND
SEVEN GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU JOIN ME IN JOINING IN
MEMORY OF NEW WALLACE.
BANKING IS AGUIAR-CURRY.
MS BAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF CAN
HOFFMAN. A RESIDENT OF LAFAYETTE
WHO PASSED AWAY ON APRIL TWENTY
SECOND.
KEN WAS BORN ON FEBRUARY
FIFTEENTH IN NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE IN OAKLAND HE ATTENDED
SCHOOL IT FREMONT HIGH SCHOOL
AND LATER STUDIED FOR TWO YEARS
AT SAINT MARY'S COLLEGE BEFORE
GRADUATING FROM THE MERCHANT
MARINE ACADEMY. I KINGS POINT IN
NEW YORK AND HE BEGAN A CAREER
IN CONTRACTING AND DEVELOPMENT
AS A PLASTERING CONTRACTOR IN
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT. AND THEN
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN HE
STARTED HIS OWN COMPANY THE
HOFFMAN COMPANY A REAL ESTATE
DEVELOPMENT COMPANY BASED IN OUR
WONDERFUL NEIGHBORING COMMUNITY
OF CONCORD.
BY THE MID NINETEEN EIGHTIES
KEN'S COMPANY HAVE BUILT MORE
THAN THIRTY THOUSAND HOMES AND%
APARTMENTS
ALL THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA AND
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION WORTH. OF COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL PROPERTIES.
TODAY THE HOFFMAN COMPANY
OPERATES TWO ATHLETIC CLUBS A
YOUTH CENTER AND HER
CHAMPIONSHIP GOLF COURSE.
IN ADDITION TO BEING THE
SUCCESSFUL A BUSINESS CAN WAS A
LEADER IN THE COMMUNITY AND A
GREAT GENEROUS PHILANTHROPIST
AND FRAN. HE SERVED AS TO TIME
PRESIDENT AND MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND AS A MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF HOME BUILDERS.
HE ALSO SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AND REGION EMERITUS FOR
SAINT MARY'S COLLEGE AND IS A
MEMBER WAS A MEMBER OF THE US
MERCHANT MARINE ACADEMY ALUMNI
ASSOCIATION.
ON TOP OF THAT CAN SERVE AS AN
EX DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL FISH
AND WILDLIFE FOUNDATION FOR TEN
YEARS.
USING THE FUNDS FROM HIS
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS CAN
DONATED MILLIONS TO THE DAILY
SAU HIGH SCHOOL IN CONCORD IT
STIRS UP EAST BAY STUDENTS ALL
THROUGHOUT THE AREA. AND ALSO
OPEN THE DEALER SALAD ACADEMY
WHICH PROVIDES FOOD AND BOOKS
AND TUTORING FOR YOUTH OF THE
GREATEST NEED TO HELP THEM
PREPARE FOR HIGH SCHOOL. AND
HELP PROVIDE A FOOTBALL FIELD A
BASKETBALL GYM AND A FOOTBALL
SCHOLARSHIP AT SAINT MARY'S
COLLEGE.
HIS GENEROSITY EXTENDED TO MANY
LOCAL CAUSES SUCH AS DUCKS
UNLIMITED AND THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL.
ASSOCIATION AND FROM MY OWN
PERSONAL INVOLVEMENT THE
REGIONAL THEATRE FOR THE ARTS
AND WALNUT CREEK THERE'S
ACTUALLY HOFFMAN THEATER. IN THE
REGIONAL THEATER AND WALNUT
CREEK WHERE THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN A YEAR SEE ARTS
PROGRAMS AND HAVE FOUND THEIR
FIRST ACCESS TO ARTS. OF FROM
BALLET TO THE SYMPHONY TO THE
THEATER.
HE'S ALSO BEEN A FOUNDER OF THE
MOUNT ABLA MEDICAL CENTER.
AND ASIDE FROM THESE EFFORTS IN
BUSINESS AND OTHER PHILANTHROPY
CAN IT WAS A WELL KNOWN CO OWNER
OF THE OAKLAND EIGHTIES.
HE AND STEVEN SCOTT PURCHASE
PA'S IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE TO
SAVE THE TEAM FROM MOVING FROM
THE BAY AREA THANK GOODNESS.
AND IT HIS FREE TIME HE ENJOYS
THE OUTDOORS IN ADDITION TO
BASEBALL ALL KINDS OF ACTIVITIES
IS GOLF AND HUNTING AND FISHING.
KEN IS SURVIVED BY HIS WONDERFUL
WIFE JEAN AND HIS TWO DAUGHTERS.
HE.
WAS JUST A WONDERFUL PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY AS YOU CAN HEAR HIS
FOR PHILANTHROPY A BUILDING
HOMES THAT MANY FAMILIES HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO ENJOY THROUGHOUT
THE BAY AREA. AND OF COURSE I'M
SHARED HIS PASSION FOR THE EASE
WITH ALL OF US I OFFER MY
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO KEN'S
FRIENDS AND FAMILY ALL
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITY AND ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
THEY CAN IS BAKER MISTER GRAYSON
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IT IS WITH
GREAT SADNESS THAT I ALSO RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
A GOOD FRIEND A COMMUNITY
LEADER.
IN THE BAY AREA AND THAT WAS KEN
HOFFMAN.
MR OFTEN SERVED AS I'M AT IN THE
MERCHANT MARINES AND VARIOUS
THEATERS DURING WORLD WAR TWO
AND EARNED A RATING OF MASTER
MARINA BEFORE BEING HONORABLY
DISCHARGED.
IT IS FROM THERE AFTER THE WAR
THAT HE AYE THAT HE ESTABLISHED
HIMSELF AS A VERY VERY
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESSMAN AND DOWN
TO THIS REAL ESTATE DEVELOPMENT
COMPANY IS A MATTER OF FACT. HE
WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN BUILDING
MUCH OF THE HOUSING MILITARY
HOUSING IN CONCORD CALIFORNIA IT
IS THERE. THAT OF THE MILITARY
WAS OFFERING A CERTAIN PRICE FOR
EVERY HOUSING UNIT.
AND AS A DEVELOPER.
MISTER HOFFMAN SAW THAT HE WAS
MAKING THOSE HOUSES I OF
CREATING OR BUILDING THOSE
HOUSING UNITS FOR MUCH MUCH LESS
AND FELT LIKE. IT WAS WAY TOO
MUCH OF THE MILITARY WAS
OFFERING AND PAYING AND TAX
DOLLARS WE ACTUALLY WENT BACK TO
WASHINGTON CONVINCE THE MILITARY
TO DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THEY WERE PAYING PER HOUSING
UNIT. COSTING HIMSELF IN HIS OWN
COMPANY BUT HE FELT LIKE THAT
WAS THE HONEST THING TO DO AND
MAKING SURE THAT WOULD THAT THEY
SPENT TAX DOLLARS CORRECTLY. SO
HE WAS A VERY VERY HONORABLE MAN
AS WELL AS THE FACT THAT HE WAS
PASSIONATE ABOUT EDUCATION AND
THE OUTDOORS. AND IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN HE WAS ASKED TO
REFLECT ON HIS LEGACY THIS
RESPONSE
WAS FOCUSED ON THIS ONE THING
THE IMPORTANCE.
PLACED ON GIVING BACK AND MAKING
SURE FUTURE GENERATIONS WERE
EXPOSED DEAD TO.
NATURE TO THE WETLANDS AND
WATERFOWL PROTECTION IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO OVERSTATE THE
POSITIVE IMPACT MISTER HOFFMAN
HAD ON CALIFORNIA AND ESPECIALLY
MY DISTRICT DURING HIS LIFETIME
AND I ASK THAT THE ASSEMBLY
RESPECTFULLY ADJOURNED IN HIS
MEMORY TO HONOR. ALL OF HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
SUCH A SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY MAY EIGHTH CHECK IN
SESSION.
WEDNESDAY MAY NINTH CHECK IN
AND THURSDAY MAY TENTH FLOOR
SESSION AT NINE A. M..
ALL OTHER ITEMS WE'LL BE PASSED
IN RETAIN ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER. BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER HOLDEN MOVES MS BAKER
SECONDS.
THE HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY MAY TENTH AT NINE AM.
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED
IT IS A VOTE CHANGE. HOLDEN.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE.
FROM I TO NOT VOTING.
VOTECHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
FIFTY ONE I'D SAY NOT VOTING